what does that mean
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the secret meaning
of alberto's catchphrase and explaining
the many other hidden details and themes
you might have missed in the end of
lucca
spoilers ahead so take care the movie's
bittersweet ending finds both luca and
alberto
seizing the chance for bright new future
with luca leaving for genoa where he'll
pursue his passion for study while
alberto finds the father figure he
longed for in massimo
and as the pair tearfully leave each
other alberto repeats the phrase he said
to luca when they first met
pierce back then when luca first asked
him what that meant alberto amusingly
changed the subject but now at the end
of the movie he admits he never actually
knew
go find out for me will ya director
enrico casa rosa has since explained
that alberto's catchphrase is a pun
that comes from his own childhood with
the words piacere girolomotronbeta
translating roughly as nice to meet you
my name is twisty trombone
notice how alberto twists his hand and
then pulls and pushes luca's arm during
the handshake mimicking the twist in the
name as well as a slide of a trombone
there's also a double meaning embedded
in this phrase firstly the word girolamo
is a play on the italian giro la mano
which means i turn
my hand hence the twisty meaning part of
the pun
secondly durolamor is also the italian
equivalent of the name jerome which
would make the literal translation of
the phrase
pleased to meet you my name is jerome
like the stupido phrase humor comes from
the fact that this is something alberto
overheard one day and didn't really
understand what it means
it's a human thing i'm kind of an expert
so although he kind of used it correctly
when he first met luca
the second time he uses it he's
basically saying pleased to meet you as
they say goodbye which makes their
farewell even more touching in a way as
he's saying he's happy to know his
friend
the double meanings of alberto's parting
phrase nicely reflect the bigger theme
of the character's dual nature in the
movie which is highlighted again in
those final moments as the reign
transforms alberto back into his sea
monster form and the same happens to
luca as the train pulls out of the
tunnel with both of them no longer
afraid to show their true nature to the
world
that theme of difference and how
individuals may choose or feel
forced to keep their real selves a
secret was also addressed in various
other moments from the end of the movie
when luca sees his friend alberto
cruelly trapped in a net by erkole after
the rain reveals his sea serpent nature
he decides he won't pretend to be
someone he isn't
anymore as he did earlier when he shamed
alberto for revealing himself as a sea
monster
in a powerful moment lucas sheds his
colander safety helmet and comes to his
friend's rescue revealing his own true
colours at the same time
on another level luca pagoda whose
surname means hermit crab in italian
is symbolically casting off the
protective shell he's worn until now
something that hermit crabs do in real
life as they grow and seek out a better
fitting shell
or home this scene is crucial for many
reasons as it has the power to speak to
anyone who's felt the need to hide who
they really are
for fear of rejection intolerance and
even violence from society
which is one reason why luca and
alberto's transformations have been so
readily seen as a metaphor for the lgbtq
plus
community it's interesting then that the
feathery scaling effect of mystique's
transformation scenes and the x-men
films which are also allegories for
lgbtq plus experiences was one of the
major inspirations for the way that
lucas animators designed the
transformation of the sea monsters in
this movie
shortly after that we get another
similar moment when the two old ladies
reveal a secret it feels like they've
been hiding for a very long time that
they
too are sea monsters what these two old
ladies
represent is open for the viewer to
decide for themselves
on the one hand their names conchetta
and pinocchia
may suggest that they are the aunts or
some other relatives of the underwater
augusta family who luca talks to at the
beginning of the movie
hi mrs hey luca and you could also
definitely view their sea monster
reveals as a metaphor for their coming
out
making them a lesbian couple who've been
living in secret in a society that they
felt would not
openly accept them given the 50s to 60s
period that lucas set in
the reality of gay couples living
together claiming to be relatives or
just platonic friends was not uncommon
check out the touching netflix
documentary secret love for example
also notice how the two ladies in lucca
live on the outskirts of town near the
old tower and nod towards their feeling
of being outsiders and needing somewhere
they could be safe
casaroza specifically addressed these
metaphors in an interview with
film where he explained that he loved
the idea that the film explores the
feeling of otherness and difference
and he added that the story is about a
person making the decision to say
here i am let the chips fall where they
may i'm gonna fly my flag and i don't
care
the film also acknowledges that other
people's acceptance of who you are
isn't necessarily something that will
either come easily or sometimes even at
all but what's important is finding your
own tribe so that you can thrive
some people they'll never accept him but
some will and he
seems to know how to find the good ones
as casaroza says
good friends are important because they
are the people that see you for who you
are and they don't care about whatever
differences you have and you can see
this and how luca and julia support each
other's passions
just promise you tell me everything you
see
sorry too much never sorry
too much no way we also see this theme
of outsiders and the feeling of being
rejected or feared by society and
several other characters
er coler the villain of this story calls
luca and alberto
out of towners before proceeding to mock
the way they dress and use his goons to
bully the pair
julia lives with her mother in genoa for
most of the year and doesn't feel
fully accepted by the community in
puerto roco when she comes to visit her
father
every summer i come here and everyone
thinks i'm just some weird kid who
doesn't belong which is one reason she
may feel especially drawn to luca and
alberto
another reason being his strong sense of
justice against society's intolerance as
represented by erkole it's a long evil
empire of injustice
and when massimo refers to his
disability pointing out that he was born
that way and that his right arm wasn't
bitten off by a sea monster
the film is making the point that we
shouldn't make assumptions about people
based on their appearances
showing disability as something that
simply exists
and is just one part of who someone is
is all too rare on screen so it's good
to see it here
massimo himself shows how a person can
overcome their fears of what they think
of as the other
as he progresses from being obsessed
with hunting sea monsters to adopting
alberto and even visiting luca's sea
monster family during the end credits
even edcoli's sidekicks decide they've
had enough of being abused by him at the
end of the film
and reject him and what he represents by
tossing him into the town fountain
which is what he tried to do to luca
when he first met him
casaroza says that he loves the idea
that the film scene monsters are a way
for the audience to come in
and bring their own experience of
feeling other and project their own
sense of difference onto it
now i want to mention a few other
details you might have missed from the
end of the movie
as the credits roll the accompanying
images reveal the story of what happened
after luca left porto rosso we can see
that massimo has fully adopted alberto
as his son
and when he gives him a knife for a
birthday present it pays off this
earlier scene in the movie which knife
do i get huh
you don't and as well as helping out
massimo alberto now also seems to have a
job as a lifeguard
also the statue of the town's famed sea
monster killer appears to have been
replaced by lucas stone statue of
himself that he used as a decoy for his
illicit trips to the surface which shows
just how much
attitudes have changed in puerto rosso
as for luca and julia they get a dog
together called neurone
the italian name for the roman emperor
nero the turtle from the island that
held up the ramp for alberto and luca's
homemade vesper jump has been adopted
too and given the name
caligula and many thanks to piogeo who
commented on my easter eggs video that
caligula was a mad roman emperor who
named his horse a senator and ordered a
war against the sea god neptune
machiavelli has a litter of kittens many
of which are mini mustachioed versions
of him
and his name is a reference to the
italian writer and political philosopher
whose most famous work the prince has a
notable quote that men
usually judge things by the eye rather
than by the hand
everyone sees what you appear to be but
few feel what you are
which feels especially pertinent to the
story of luca
some other little details you might have
missed in the end credits include luca
and julia indulging their joy of space
as they watch the moon landing which as
charles lee
points out was in 1969. there's also a
lady in the [ __ ] easter egg with two
cats sharing a plate of spaghetti
and the cheese basil garlic and nuts
that appear at the end of the credits
and most of the ingredients needed to
make classic pesto an essential part of
julia's favorite pasta dish
i made your favorite el pesto the
post-credits scene
also reveals what might have been in
store for lucca if he'd ended up going
to the deep with his uncle ugo
as the strange fish chatters on about
how great life is at the bottom of the
sea
well carcass anyway you're gonna have
fun
the visual punch line at the end though
is that all this time
ogo's been talking to a solitary goat
fish who sidles off once he realizes
exactly what life's going to be like
with uggor in the deep
a fun theory i had in which scepter man
also noticed is that this goat fish
could be enrico who luca mentioned at
the beginning of the movie
you want to run off like your buddy
enrico because
i've got news for you he's either dead
or he's
out there somewhere i also love their
idea that that line could be a finding
nemo reference
too on top of that this goat fish enrico
is quite likely also a reference to
director enrico cazarroza himself who
grew up in italy but left his home to go
to new york and pursue his passion for
animation
eventually getting to work and direct
films at pixar
in fact casaroza has said that luca's
story very much
channels his own childhood and how as a
shy kid of 11 he met his real-life best
friend alberto who is a much more
boisterous character
just like the one in the movie
alternately the goat fish with uncle ugo
might be giuseppe who had a habit of
drifting off by himself
and thanks to just someone who pointed
out that the scene may also be a nod to
finding nemo's post-credits scene in
which an anglerfish with a glowing lure
like
uncle ugos gets eaten up by tiny little
green fish
now as great as the ending of luca was
the original story was going to be
incredibly
different with a big battle and alberto
turning into a giant kraken i'll be
explaining all that in my next luca
video and another link to watch it here
and in the video description
as soon as it's ready so what did you
think of luca alberto and julia's story
and what does the movie mean for you
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
don't forget to hit that thumbs up
and share it's hugely appreciated you
can tap left to discover all the pixar
easter eggs in lucca including inside
out up
pizza planet and many more or tap right
for something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers